(audience cheers)
(upbeat pop music)
♪ My baby, he don't talk sweet ♪
♪ He ain't got much to say ♪
♪ But he loves me, loves me, loves me ♪
♪ I know that he loves me anyway ♪
♪ And maybe he don't dress fine ♪
♪ But I don't really mind ♪
♪ 'Cause every time he pulls me near ♪
♪ I just wanna cheer ♪
♪ Let's hear it for the boy ♪
♪ Oh, let's give the
boy a hand, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Let's hear it for my baby ♪
♪ You know you gotta
understand, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Maybe he's no Romeo ♪
♪ But he's my lovin' one-man show ♪
♪ Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa ♪
♪ Let's hear it for the boy ♪
(upbeat pop music)
♪ My baby may not be rich ♪
♪ He's watchin' every dime ♪
♪ But he loves me, loves me, loves me ♪
♪ We always have a real good time ♪
♪ And maybe he sings off key ♪
♪ But that's all right by me, yeah ♪
♪ 'Cause what he does, he does so well ♪
♪ Makes me wanna yell ♪
♪ Let's hear it for the boy ♪
♪ Oh, let's hear it for my man ♪
♪ Let's hear it for my man ♪
♪ Let's hear it for my baby ♪
♪ Let's hear it for the boy ♪
♪ Let's hear it for my man ♪
(audience cheers and applauds)